hello and welcome back to the shakey
Simon show so today we'll be looking at
the question what makes the circadian
clock tick TTFN L so in the last video I
introduced you to the concept of the
circadian clock and the circadian rhythm
and what that's about and how it is
important for coordinating different
responses in the body so check out that
video the links in the description but
this video will address how the
circadian clock operates molecularly and
the keep rating factors and genes that
are involved in regulating this process
now work on the discovery of some of
these key factors by these three guys
here Geoffrey Howe micros patch and Mark
young led to them bring awarded the 2017
napal Prize in Physiology or medicine so
in the last video I gave you knows about
but brief introduction to the key
components involved in coordinating this
24-hour cycle so in this video I hope to
give you more insight into the what
these different factors are doing and
how this process is operating so because
we're mammals I will focus on the
mammalian key components in this video
so the four key components to get to
grips with is clock female born cry or
cryptochrome and paths or periods and
just add a bit to the complexity you
have cry one and you have cry 2 and
there are three different copies of the
periods protein and so parts of the
proteins functions
requires that clock and beam r1 interact
with each other and likewise cry and
purr interact with each other as well to
carry out some of their functions so
what is that function so the call
circadian clock factors acts to
coordinate the T t fo and so T TF o is
the transcription translation feedback
loop and so this is the belief that
regulates the 24-hour cycle in the
circadian rhythm it is what makes sure
that the rhythm is around 24 hours and
feedbacks on itself and this is the
negative feedback with delay that we
spoke about in the last video so how do
these korkin
see the Sun so let's start with clock
and beam r1 so as I mentioned previously
clock and Beamer one former diamond
together and they are both transcription
factors so this means that they regulate
the expression of different genes so to
perform their role they need to be in
the nucleus of the cell and so
interestingly two of the genes that
clock and Bhima one regulate the
expression of our cryptochrome and
periods and they promote the expression
of these two genes so in addition to
those two they regulates a whole
plethora of other genes as well but of
interest to the negative feedback we're
talking about here crimped cream and
power of the most interest so quiet and
paths go into the cytosol to get
translated into protein and it's their
protein products that then go back into
the nucleus and they act to repress the
activity of clock and beam r1 so by
repressing the activity of clock and
Bhima one they effectively repressed the
promotion of their own gene expression
see if that made any sense what's
happening is that cry and purr are
acting to prevents their own expression
and this therefore reduces the level of
protein inside so and so it is thought
that their synthesis and their
repression of synthesis is what
coordinates the 24-hour timescale of the
circadian clock but this is just one
leap of three main interconnected loops
that help to coordinate and keep the
robustness of this 24-hour cycle so
let's just briefly recap what we've
covered so far
so that is clock and Bhima one drive the
expression of cryptogram and periods in
addition to cryptochrome in periods they
also drive the expression of rev AB and
BA and so these two laser proteins that
are interconnected with the other loop
because they act to regulate the
expression of B male 1 so rev up acts to
repress the expression of female 1
whereas brought activate suits and so
the third leap considered to be most
important for the regulation of the
circadian clock is the BP which is the
d-box binding protein
and so DPP is interconnected because one
of his binding proteins is regulated by
the competition between rev up and roll
so rev up and roll control the
expression of a protein that interacts
with DBP which is the third loop office
interconnected loop system that keeps a
robust 24 hour roughly rhythm that is
important for the circadian clock but
even with these complicating
interconnected loops of the regulation
of gene expression this doesn't fully
complete the understanding of how we get
every bus 24-hour rhythm in addition to
synthesis there's also protein
degradation which is also critical to
the regulation and robustness of the
circadian rhythm so in particular it
seems that the degradation of the
protein periods and the protein crypt
cream is important for completing the
24-hour cycle so cryptochrome gets
degraded when it is phosphorylated by
ampk which is a kinase protein and so
this additional phosphates enables it to
be recognized by fbx l3 which then
triggers cry for degradation
similarly periods also gets
phosphorylated but this time by the
protein C k1 Delta or epsilon and the
additional phosphates that enables it to
be recognized by the beta t RCP protein
which then causes period to be degraded
as well so this protein degradation acts
in addition to the repression of gene
expression that was law earlier to make
sure that they've period encrypt chrome
levels decrease before they then
increase during the next cycle of the
circadian rhythm so I've put a link to
this paper here in the description for
more information
and more detailed information about the
mammalian components involved in
regulating the circadian clock but
hopefully this video has given you an
overview into the different factors and
how they cooperates and are
interconnected and this creates a robust
feedback mechanism to keep a 24-hour
cycle